we have heard from the foreign secretary
don't it Rob earlier in the program
saying that despite this nor passed by
Parliament saying that Boris Johnson
must extend if you can't get a deal
he will not extend what do you make of
the government position I think it's
extraordinary and the foreign secretary
has a legal background himself the idea
that a sitting Prime Minister in one of
the oldest democracies on the planet
would say I will ignore the law and he
was saying I know it's not ignoring the
law it's just testing and it's a little
bit is that what we say to our kids is
that what we say to poor working people
vulnerable people in this country oh
it's not breaking the law it's just
testing a bit I think the position is
irresponsible and elitist the idea
there's one law for Boris Johnson and
his mates and another law for everyone
else it's appalling I mean what they
would say is that they are trying to
enact the will of the people that
they're trying to do what Parliament is
trying to block and I know what they'd
say but every tin-pot dictator on the
planet throughout history has used the
excuse of having the people on their
side to break the law to shut down
Parliament and all the rest of it is
absolutely extraordinary and I think
it's very um British as was the purge of
the 21 the 21 MPs who are conservatives
you know they're not secret Corbin
Easter's I noticed the way that Dominic
Rob mentioned jeremy corbyn's name about
about hundred times in his in his
interview as if as if Jeremy Corbyn is
that it's the scary one I think a lot of
people will look at the behavior of
these this number 10 in recent weeks and
decide that the person who's being on
British and anti-democratic is Boris
Johnson I mean they don't Rob also
federal interview that the government
would not break the law he said they
just want to test the position well the
legislation is crystal clear if you
don't have a deal
in the next few weeks you have to apply
to the extension it's a it's a duty
that's laid in the legislation on the
Prime Minister personally the law is
crystal clear I thought he was
thoroughly unconvincing and
mealy-mouthed on on that there's a
there's a legal opinion published in The
Observer today I'm a number of QC s
making it crystal clear that if you
don't abide by that legislation people
start going to court and and then if you
ignore court orders you're in contempt
of court we don't want to be in that
place that does that mean if you are in
contempt of court if you're in contempt
of court then you're breaching a court
order just like anybody who've ever
breached an ASBO or anything else and
you are facing you know sanctions that
we do not want for any minister let
alone a primary talkback prison you know
this is the sort of stuff that that what
I think is going on here is that Johnson
& Co deliberately using breaking the law
as a kind of dog whistle because they
think it makes them look tough but I
just think it makes them look appalling
which is why I want this to be sorted
out in Parliament which is by shutting
down Parliament and seeking to dissolve
Parliament tomorrow so that you can
crash out it is terrible so we need to
we need to make yes we're going to have
a general election it's going to be
sooner rather than later it'll be weeks
not months but we will not allow them to
use their sort of chaos theory and crash
out without Parliament being able to to
have it say the thing is they are saying
that they don't want to be in this
position and they are willing to go to
the public to find out what the public
thinks you have more democracy and
corner and election and it's the Labour
Party that is blocking that so we will
have an election and today we've
launched our voter registration campaign
and it's really important that all your
viewers whatever their views on brexit
or on whether they prefer Boris Johnson
or Jeremy Corbyn to be Prime Minister
everyone should be registering to vote
so they can have their say it's going to
be sooner rather than later but we
cannot crash out by default with in a
general election period and we cannot
allow Boris Johnson and his colleagues
to manipulate the date of the general
election so that we rush that's what
they would say you're doing that you're
trying to manipulate the date of the
general election so that it's after that
deadline when I just have a quick look
at so I'm sure that John McDonald said
on this show so at last weekend he
said let me just say a message to Boris
Johnson value general election bring it
on absolutely to bring it on
well I still say bring it on and it's
just we won't allow you to crash Britain
out contrary to the will of Parliament
and without putting that option to the
people but before they've had that
opportunity I'm talking I'm talking
weeks not months we're launching our
voter registration campaign today is
going to be very soon but I won't I
won't stand by where you've got a prime
minister who shuts down Parliament who
purchase his once broadchurch party and
and tries to crash us out before there's
been a general election that would be
that would be wholly undemocratic so
you're talking about weeks not months I
just came to try and pin down what you
mean by that do you mean there will be a
general election in weeks not months or
do you mean that you'll give your the
green light and weeks not months well I
think but I think quite quite possibly
but I mean forgive me but things are
moving very fast and the other thing I
would say is that yes Jeremy Corbyn is
the leader of the Opposition but but
there are people in in other opposition
parties and people like the conservative
rebels who all share this approach that
it would be thoroughly irresponsible to
behave like I don't know the Joker in
the Dark Knight or something like that
and just go for chaos theory and I'm
just really worried that there are some
people in number 10 at the moment who
literally believe in causing chaos and
fear and polarization on the streets in
order to in order to get there their way
and deliver and no deal brexit that
Parliament didn't vote for the people
didn't vote for so they can do their
their cozy deals with their mates in the
Trump's white house I understand your
frustration about what's happening in
number talent that's coming through very
clearly but I just really want to pin
you down on the timing is here because
this is important are you saying that
you are happy to have an election as
long as it's past that mid-october the
council are you saying you're having to
have an election as long as it's after
the 31st deadline what does that what
you want so so obviously I don't speak
for all the
position leaders I'm just the I'm just
the legal adviser to the shadow
government but what I have been
instructed at this point to say and what
I believe is the priority is that we
have to guarantee that we don't crash
out in an election period and we have to
guarantee that this incumbent in number
10 is not able to use his willingness to
to disobey the law and to manipulate a
general election date so the crash now
happens before we've had the opportunity
for that election those are the
priorities and so it's going to take
perhaps a few weeks to lock that down
but as soon as we've locked down those
things that have just said to you we
want that we want that election oh
goodness oh goodness I mean goodness me
I said I certainly hope so
okay now you're talking there about
you're worried about what number 10 are
doing but there will be some people who
will look at the Labour Party's position
and think you just don't like democracy
because you don't want an election right
now even though it's what you've been
calling for for years they'll be saying
that you not accepting the result of
referendum because you effectively think
that people got it wrong so you want
people to have another go until they
give you the right answer why do you not
trust the public no I do trust the
public and that's why I want a general
election just not yet I'm talking I'm
talking because I don't want people to
have the opportunity note for No Deal no
sure just to be clear if if we have an
election it is perfectly reasonable for
Boris Johnson and his chums to say vote
for us and we'll give you No Deal that's
what he would now I mean but what I'm
worried about is crashing out without
the people having had their say in an
election you see my point
because it's dirty tricks it's
undemocratic dirty tricks where you say
we ignore Parliament and we may we may
manipulate and weak nor the law we
ignore Parliament and we will keep the
power to set the election date
manipulate the election day so that we
crash out before that
election may have happened and we are
talking about ruthless ruthless people
who will sit here and smile at you and
say we'll test the law but that means
ignore the law we're talking about
people who will purge their Parsi of
people I disagree with like Ken Clark
and and Justine greening and Nicolas
Soames and and all the rest I've agreed
with them on some rule a basic rule of
law civil liberties issues but of course
I disagree with them about austerity and
how to tackle poverty but now we are
dealing with people who are
anti-democratic ante rule of law I want
the general election as soon as possible
but I cannot allow these people to shut
down Parliament and ignore the law in
the meantime at the same time now it's
not just the Conservative Party who are
effectively having issues keeping their
party together is it there are people on
labour side as well who are wrestling
with these issues to one person for
example John Mann Labour MP wants to
step down and become an anti Semitism
and for adviser and he gave a quote to
The Sunday Times today where he said
korban has given the green light to the
anti-semites and having done so has sat
there and done nothing to turn that
round he's not just hijacked my
political party
he's hijacked its soul as ethics and I
will never forgive him for that
so there are people on your side team
before their party has been hijacked
well obviously I disagree with with John
Mann he's one of two MPs that voted
against the legislation - to prevent a
crash out he's obviously very unhappy
and on those Labour benches at the
moment and so he has made his decision
and I personally wish him well in his in
his future work are you alarmed by the
news that the first Labour MP to be
fighting a resection ahead of the next
election is Donna Johnson last year
backbencher of the Year someone who has
done some campaigning work on the blood
contamination scandal so what I would
say about and because you'll appreciate
I'm not an MP and I've not had to go
through these hoops that these people
have to do as members of parliament
representing their people what I would
say is having looked into it and being
about the the process and having a
trigger back having this this trigger
system does not mean that she's been
deselected
it's very common I'm told it means she
has to go through the roof election
process I heard of an election and
there'll be a look there'll be a
shortlist it'll be an all-women
shortlists picket and no doubt she'll no
doubt she'll be she'll be on it it's not
I don't believe that this is a targeted
or from what I've heard and I've looked
into it for the reasons you suggest this
is not some this is not some plot or
some factional polarization issue that
that there may be some other people like
this but it's not organized it's not
targeted it's not polarized and it's
perfectly possible that she will sail
through it and and be the candidate and
if at some point if when we get to the
election there's a need to stop that
that suspend that local democracy are a
democratic party so it's quite important
that MPs are answerable to to their
local party but if at some point we get
too close to the election then it will
be the National Executive of the party
that that keeps or suspends that process